I'm sure all of us use, routinely,
services on the internet such as email through
Google or Yahoo. And perhaps purchase things
using eBay or make orders for airline reservations
and so on. And when we do that, we think of an enterprise that we are accessing
from our work station or laptop or personal mobile device. We think of an
enterprise as a monolithic entity. But, in
fact, if you look inside the enterprise, the
enterprise, the intra enterprise view, is pretty
complicated. There's a whole bunch of services and
servers that are interconnected, there may be
marketing division, the sales division, the production division,
inventory division, the research division, and so on.
All of these constitute what an enterprise is.
So internally the view of the enterprise is much
more complex than what you see from the outside
coming in and using services provided by a particular
enterprise. Things get a lot more complicated in this day
and age because when we access an enterprise, in
fact, the enterprises, they talk to one another. And
this is, what is usually called a supply chain
model, and so on. Where, the service that you are,
requesting may not be serviced by, a single entity but may actually involve the
entity that you're contacting, contacting other entities
in order to. Put together a solution for
a particular request, and what is even
more challenging is when enterprises merge. For instance,
if three companies merge together, and this
happened a while back. There's a company called
Digital Equipment Corporation that got bought out by
Compaq and those two merged, and later on
HP bought out Compaq. And so you can see, that when things like this happen, the
inter-enterprise view is much more complex. And now
when companies merge like this, the idea of
an enterprise, the idea of an enterprise, becomes
an amalgam of three different entities coming together,
in this example for instance. So
the enterprise transformation challenges are many: interoperability
of the systems that constitute different
enterprises, interface compatibility when such merging happens,
system evolution. You know, things are
not stagnant, now this transformed enterprise has
to continuously evolve as well. Scalability,
reliability and the cost of maintaining a
complex system like that. All of these things are the
challenges that have to be faced both internally and across enterprises.